the Joe Rogan experience but any of
those old schoolers yeah that's the
point at this at funny it's it's in true
story where I talk about how those guys
who are such icons couldn't make it
today because they take too long you
could take you could take two minutes
before you got to the punchline you
could take two minutes to set something
up
the audience was perfectly okay with
that you could never do that today Jack
Benny he and Bob Hope was more
rapid-fire but a lot of these old
schoolers you know I mean I have a never
funny list
being a friend of mine created years ago
and some of them are on it you know
Danny Thomas and I don't know when
Skelton I mean there's some people I
thought were never Bill Cosby I must say
so it was on that list really oh yeah
you know I thought he was funny never
thought he was funny even when he was
doing Bill Cosby himself like back at
the album days and I may have missed
some stuff he did but everything I ever
heard even when I was a kid I saw him on
TV I'm like no I feel very very ahead of
my time I never liked him I do well it
was one of those things where if you had
said any of this that you're saying 10
years ago people have been furious at
you well now these been exposed
somebody told me he was a creep back in
1983 okay someone told me in 94 yeah
yeah so it was somebody I liked not
somebody I was romantically involved
with but a girl who he was horrible to
and I never liked him after that as a
person that makes sense I had heard from
people on the set of news radio that he
drugged girls it was like one of those
weird things you heard as a room like
why does he do yeah he drugged girls
like Bill Cosby right cause he blew
Cosby we're talking about the same guy
it's not like Steve McQueen steam
McQueen will get them confused right no
I mean my dad America and you have to
wonder why a guy who could
get laid yeah even as a married man
that's obviously a sick kink he had but
I also know a guy who was a promoter and
and told incredibly ridiculous stories
about things that Bill Cosby did that
were not sexual but just informed me
that what his kink is is part of a much
larger sickness about control yeah and
making people do weird things because he
can let me tell you what I heard then
you tell me what you heard I heard he
makes people watch him eat curry he
would make the whole staff come into his
dressing room and watch him eat I hadn't
heard that exactly but it's exactly in
line with what I heard that he would do
things like make you what was one of
them like he would order food and then
he would say you know scoop out the the
doughy part of the hamburger bun after
you wash your hands and put it back on
the hamburger or once he asked them to
send him the soap that he hadn't
finished using in the dressing room like
Glenn did to him send it yeah just like
crazy crazy [ __ ] that again speaks to a
pathology that's larger than what we
know about him sexually that that fear
as a subcategory under that because to
need to have the woman be unconscious
yeah that's that's a weird thing I can't
I can't I can't get into there's certain
things I think I can't even imagine why
someone would find it attractive most to
be with a child no I can't understand
why that would be appealing to you I
can't understand this you know a lot of
things I can't understand I worked at a
casino and he made the security guard
talk him into bed yep and shut the
lights off things like I'm gonna live
and I want you to tuck me in shut Eliza
he had like a whole routine that he
wanted them to follow and he wanted them
to tuck him into bed yeah well I had a
friend who had an interesting take on it
and he said there is something that
happens to some famous people spurt ick
you'll early famous people who were
famous a long time ago where they feel
like they are better than other people
there is a giant gap between them and
other people and they feel like they can
do things to people and they what yeah I
don't think that's uncommon but his
pathology but most people try to hide
that I think I'd that feeling they try
to I think he did you know it's called
acting yes that's why when they're in
front of the camera they're so charming
but we know that behind the scenes there
they're not but he seemed to wear it on
his sleeve well sort of sometimes right
but the other thing that he was doing in
publicly she was trying to chastise
other comics for using bad words and you
know he had a lot of weird control
issues with that as well but my friends
taken it was that he thinks that there
are people that they get to this
position where they think that they're
owed things and he thought about that
sexually - he said he probably felt like
he was just so above those women that he
didn't even want to negotiate with them
but just drugged them and [ __ ] them
because he's Bill Cosby and they should
be happy yeah it's crazy it's no it's no
you know the human mind is the bottom of
the ocean it's mostly unexplored a giant
mystery well especially that kind of
scenario I mean how many human beings
have ever experienced what he's
experienced he's been famous since the
1950s right who's an American icon right
is rich beyond the bracer groundbreaker
and a legitimate world-class stand-up
comic who toured the whole world created
yes Cosby Show that was a groundbreaking
television oh yeah so many factors so
many factors and then on top of that a
psychotic pervert and a creep and
drugging women I mean on top and who
knows what else other [ __ ] [ __ ]
you're probably not just that know you
know when someone's that [ __ ] up it's
probably not just they might find like
cats in his backyard who knows the
[ __ ] guys in - well I somebody told
me it just may not be true that he was
drugging people with animal
tranquilizers the duds he had a vet's
license or something that's how way
that's how he was because people were
like how did he get the stuff that he
was using for the knockout pills would
this would it offend you if I put my
feet up not at all why would is a man
that's a man maybe if I don't ask you
relax you're feel good I put my feet up
he rolled oh great you got some loafers
on purpose those are your choice you
wore those today I didn't even think
about it
see that's why I'm saying I love my wet
I did this because I don't have to think
about who my wardrobe but what I'm gonna
wear and yeah is Johnny gonna like me oh
boy did you the night show with Johnny
thirty times holy [ __ ]
1982 to 1992 Wow yeah 30 times yes
which just shows you that show was went
out when I started to do it there was
such a proliferation of comics that you
could do that show 30 times and that
didn't make me famous I mean it elevated
me to a degree legitimized you and show
business but that at one point just
doing the Tonight Show once made you a
star
but part of what true story is about was
the comics frustration that they came
along at a time when it wasn't that
unique a thing anymore there was too
many comics you couldn't swing a dead
cat without hitting a comic
[Applause]